all right we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 96
editor of the glorious Sunday we are
back at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
I'm extremely excited about our special
guests and we've got the anthem VIP demo
developers manipulating streamers
December MPD and make sure a problem for
to discuss so we go get right into it
I want to introduce a Lord who is not
only a true gamer he's also responsible
for some of the most informative and
stylized content in our gaming community
whether it be her YouTube first
impressions let's chat series or twitch
streams all done with a fun-loving
personality and smooth delivery
introducing the creating host of the era
cuts for the wind YouTube channel and
the first lady of press start podcast
the love of all things gears and Dark
Souls and the Twitter of the yikes squad
movement making her debut it's in the
realm of the Lord's my girl lady Erica
for the win how you doing sis I love
that intro I was waiting for you guys
thanks for having me and long overdue
huge Fatiha content you know yeah huge
fan oppressed I have got a lot of those
guys on though it's only right you are
Lord in your realm so we show you the
proper respect here at the round table
are you ready have some fun yes I'm
ready go to chat is living like the
queen we have the Four Horsemen of
gaming those original Lords of the realm
here at the round table my god most my
brother from another mother the
difficult game Conqueror and the half of
the young wolf mommy
Lord addict I do sir
live talking about nah I'm a little
tired
somebody get an early copy glad to be
what you been playing him pretty much
Resident Evil and that's all Kingdom
Hearts drop why man part of me is like
man is me his mean buggin and Kofi over
there I don't even like I've rod refused
to click on the streams like so you you
feel I got a smooth up to Kofi man you
got to get that connect man feel addict
I felt the same when he hadn't you early
I was hating both you months rent to get
it but you know you brag about that
resident evil' completion because I mean
be anything else okay so it's not good
city complete I gotta at least be clear
it's what I'm told
okay yeah so that's a pretty much it
yeah what you know it's let's go we
could add to hopefully I can get through
Claire's today and tomorrow because once
Kingdom Hearts comes out it's a wrap I
don't care everything and of course we
have our most technical gaming Lord the
solo gamer who lives for the single
player selfish experience and also the
sastra darkness
mr. offline profile Illuminati and Lord
patreon of the iron bank mommy
Lord sovereign how you doing sir I'm
good man I'm good little under the
weather you know like I was telling you
guys before the show started out dipping
and dodging that cold bug and it just
finally punched me in the face and that
caught me so that's where I'm at lady
Alexander wrote but he made it to the
realm he had took my big boy drinking my
water I'm good mostly good what sir
would you you know what I've been
playing listen when I when I heard when
I saw your guys feed in the messenger I
was like you know what I'm not even
going I'm not even going there when I
heard five hours of wait out now I would
just wait for the final game I wasn't
yeah I said let me not take time away
from res evil let me just play anthem
when it comes out that's what's up so
it's just been over as an evil exclusive
as evil man I honestly they they've done
a lot of great stuff with that game I'm
interested to see here what attic has to
say about it because I know he said he
had no nostalgia for the original so he
didn't really care about it initially so
what do you think because you just say
you played it and it blazed through the
gods we have a topic for that I mean
it's it's a good game I really enjoy it
I think it took me six and a half hours
to beat yawns you and BG were getting
into it and have all the people in
reference to the zombie difficulty
because obviously people don't feel a
completely different way I just
personally don't like a zombie in any
game she take four shots to kill I
understand why they did it and you know
at the end of the day it was a good
gameplay choice to make the game you
know feel like everything could kill you
but I personally feel like a zombie
should never take more than two shots to
kill in the head that's just me once
once I got from what I know there's like
heavier said zombies like they're bigger
they chunkier they're gonna take a good
amount they're gonna take almost a clip
it so the right at that point right then
you have to decide whether it's worth it
to do that or leave them behind and and
understand that you're gonna have to
deal with them later at some point and I
think that to me is just kind of the
beauty of of survival horror like those
decisions that you have to make you
can't you can't run around thinking
you're gonna kill everything
I personally the first time through I
just wanted there and if if there was
too many zombies I was just shooting
shooting kneecaps out I was like you
can't walk you can't walk everybody
can't walk you were dropping them you
were doing and you were doing what that
was that that was the resi before thing
was like okay I'm gonna drop you get
past you or drop you and kick you so I
you gotta remember like this is Liam pre
res Evil 4 so he doesn't have all that
hot training yet like he's just all he
does is shoot people and that's it and
you're the last boss for Leone I felt
like the only way to effectively fight
him was to run to one side of the room
and shoot him while he was walking at
you because if he even got nowhere close
to you like you couldn't you couldn't go
around him you couldn't go through you
couldn't go beside him we'd reach one
too much yeah once they get to a certain
proximity week and animation jumps in so
you have to stay out of that range
become erratic he said he talking like
from real-world zombie killing
experience any kind of
game any movie any TV show it zombie
doesn't take more damage than a Spartan
off halo I'm sorry
yeah I real estate to me everything
they've done with the games that's
irrelevant native and the article he put
out on on playback gaming done that go
check that out please um he he focused
on the two specific things that make
this version of the game so much
different right and it's the fact that
it's in third person but it's uh it's
third-person over-the-shoulder action so
you're controlling the camera at all
times unlike the original game which was
fixed camera angles and they did that to
sort of create tension to create you
know jump scares and stuff so that's
huge that that changes there and then in
addition to that the gun mechanics right
um I would say in this game if you want
to even increase the difficulty and the
scariness of it and don't use any sort
of amesys at all in this version of the
game defending this man in the chat
people like he's playing on easy I was
like that won't sound scant usually at
least plays it on normal he's only and I
agree with them like he's never played a
game like that at all he was like flying
on after beating Leon story and getting
more comfortable with this game he's
gonna Claire's on hardcore so you know
to be fair and that is if you think
about how we played these games back in
the day that's exactly how he played
them right we played them like I'm
normal
then we go back on hardcore with the
other unlocked hot weapons we try to do
speedruns shout out to Lord high res
even steeper and yeah shout the crab out
to talk about yeah overweight with a lot
of that speedrunning exactly oh did the
feeling of the game in that respect is
still the same like I still I know I'm
gonna go through Leon's I'm gonna go
through Claire's that I'm gonna go back
and do hunk and tofu and all that stuff
you know how pissed off because every
time I'm on my damn - so what he's
telling you what he just said he said he
told me don't [ __ ] about it because you
didn't pay for so you should not
complain that I got you hooked or
something and I walked away from you
I'll be on Saturday afternoon the XS
gamer the Lord of combat sports was a
bed of his convictions demands nothing
less than that premium experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
Oh beloved Lord King how you doing sir
I'm doing great because I was actually a
real good fight last night shout-out to
Adrien Broner for turning his Instagram
off distractions fight back you know
bring out the ring for two years as
surgery and stuff like that and he had a
couple of hard fights whatever um no I
don't really like fighters to take any
time off and it showed the ring rush Oh
mostly that was game they went 12 rounds
socially that was coming for the school
um but all around it was a great fight I
can't take anything away from those two
characters it was
good when depending on how I said it
would check that combat talk is up um we
play what I've been playing well what I
haven't been playing is I told you what
it was gonna be the depth was telling
you straight from the RIP this is hot
garbage hot garbage the first day I was
with the Jordan phase way I mean way I
do want to bring up is how do you have
that much of a bad launch when it comes
to a beta when you're the one that gave
out the codes it wasn't like an open
beta
Oh like I'm telling you guys right now
this is the ultimate of clusters of
clusters all right so I cannot wait to
get to that topic I'm gonna rip this
game in shreds I got a body game I'm
gonna tell you right now you're gonna
call me a fraud I know I have to buy the
game because if one of you takes your do
say I want to play King in this stupid
outfit later this morning like the first
day of school to trash and burn
I put the red or I put the riddle yeah
just put it you should have heard on an
actual Iron Man suit today that would
know if we got a lot to say I already
see father Lee the Jack King suit oh oh
I got a ready because it's obvious gonna
be labels and of course we had the Lord
of the cooperative experience and the
gaming ninja himself this should know me
lord Cognito telling you what you need
to hear playing that absolutely go just
love what they're doing just love the
fact that it's not just only master it
can we make it looks fantastic
um outrun on the switch obviously and I
know Kay gave you give you a lot of fun
for that UK dads you put me on to
someone who'd like an amazing
arrangement of the splash waivers or
guitar it was made on been rockin the
message or the switch been doing it like
a level at a time really let a game such
as yeah Erica you played that right you
are a messenger oh yeah everything's
great
yeah I love the music pass what's my
favorite like will you go to the shop
owner yeah why are you talking to go
play the games I used to hear what you
ate here for
the shop owner is the funniest thing do
you got your helmet on I strap mine and
they don't like you trying to login the
anthem right now of course the anthem
VIP demo which we will have a lot to say
on our first half but oh I'm still here
okay cool so long gaming but uh the
Lords of the realm have come forward in
the patreon and the dream daddy
challenge has been accepted to share the
conditions of the challenge and our
shout out to Lord this is the dream
daddy Charlie this is what the fans what
the round one so addict what's gonna be
the conditions going on here explain to
the people I'm just gonna play for four
hours and uninstall and act like i never
played requested your face be on stream
during this uh press start means just
play for four hours i guess with my face
on the on the stream and then leave it
just take it's just like get my avatar
like just cut off the face of put it to
pop that's me that's me I just haven't
moved in like three hours I've just in
the exact same position I haven't
breathed like yes yes a little fog as
attic has to play or I just go to chat
love it
unbelievable so that's what sells we got
the business out of the way what the
laws were playing on the way so what a
start off with lady
erika her video games just her journey
to youtube and twitch and what
eventually led her to joining one of the
very best podcasts on youtube the press
start podcast so late
our coolest off in the beginning what
was some of the first video game systems
you had and what got you into gaming
oh damn we go way back okay well I grew
up a Nintendo kid I talk about that all
the time my uncle he was like five years
older than me
so he was like my older brother he
introduced me to like the NES Super
Nintendo and I would usually get his
hand me downs because my parents were
like not about it they ain't buying me
new consoles so I played the Gameboy
through him say this I mean all of it a
couple of second kids here which Sega
system did you play if you can remember
oh shoot all of them Genesis Saturn I
love the Saturn the jeans yeah so most
of them but yeah so I grew up just
playing everything and then sometimes he
would borrow Playstations so I would get
my hands on that too but yeah just just
all pretty much all my life I can
remember just playing games and then you
brought up YouTube and all that yeah I
started that just to kind of share my
experiences and I was really into gears
so I started you know recording gears
and talking over it and it just kind of
went from there you know and press start
podcast is now now a big thing in my you
know career I guess our YouTube yeah and
you know meeting people that's what's so
great about you know the internet and
gaming and you know the community we get
to meet like-minded people so you know
one thing led to another they thought I
would be great on the podcast and so I'm
in yeah so that's how I'm the first lady
yeah I mean that's the condensed version
but yeah so like a year ago
how long before you graduate uh I want
to say it was like almost two years ago
I think it went it was like April or so
in 2017 mm-hmm something like that yeah
so then I want to back you up on your
video game system history because the
chat actually had a couple of questions
too they watch a handheld game did you
ever play like going besides Game Boy
did you ever play like game gear any
other hand hell's my cousin was like the
Sega kid he had all the Sega stuff so I
did get my hands on the game gear with
those big-ass batteries and everything
I I thought it was great though like it
was in it was in color and I was playing
Sonic I'm like this is awesome so I did
play it I didn't own it though I had a
the game I had a gameboy eventually like
this really small one I forget what they
call it or they called it at the time it
was like a red one I got it from a yard
sale yeah like I said my parents you
know they didn't have a lot of money so
I just took what I could get you know
but I did play handhelds yeah and then
right from like I said did the Super
Nintendo all the Nintendo systems let's
get to like almost I would say like the
E and you said you mentioned Dreamcast
you mentioned Saturn no transitions just
straight from that into like the the
PlayStation error or like how did that
transition uh well after like the
Gamecube I sort of I I still played
games but it was kind of rare cuz I was
working a lot I was you know I was
moving out moving out and stuff like
that later on I was working so I kind of
took a little like break from God a
little bit and then I came back when I
saw Gears of War and I was like I gotta
have it so I got the 360 yeah you case
or the 360 era brought you back you gave
yes in terms of like more being more
hardcore yeah I was like again yeah I
was all-in
sometimes that's what no that's why I do
cuz I remember the good times ahah like
man babe you know used to be so great
and I want him to return to greatness
you know I'm rooting for them too
yeah so that's kind of how I made my
return was there's war history a great
transition is far so as far as like I
know you mentioned how you got there
obviously depressed off and then your
journey content created like as far as
explaining to people about the twitch
yikes claw like what's that big of oh
man we're getting back into this well I
pretty much to sum it up like I turned a
bad situation into a good one like I
embraced some hate I was getting during
around every was around the time when
Spiderman came out gosh and uh Kofi had
tweeted out a couple pictures that
looked a little suspect
like yeah I remember and what happened
was i retweeted his pictures and I said
Yanks question marks and everything and
a lot of people came for me they were
really upset like about that so what I
did was like I just kept saying it I
guess and then my my viewers started
saying it and then I started getting a
little more consistent on Twitch I'm
like you know I need to make some some
badges I need to make some emotes and it
just it just came to me
yikes I gotta throw it in there and then
it just became the yikes squad from
there shout out to those puddles
everybody shout out to those yeah it's
like a blessing in disguise I guess
enjoy yeah question for you guys a
female gamer I always want to get your
overall perspective of the gaming
community like maybe some things you've
encountered I'll see that was one right
good part of the portal game but I know
one thing even though you have that
laid-back demeanor don't let lady lady
fool you she's about to smoke she would
get what a clap back game was crazy
experience as a female gamer now like in
social media in this game in community
like you know your overall perspective
on it just on on being a female gamer
well just yeah your experiences in the
gaming community yeah as a female game
uh I don't know you know every time I
kind of hear women talking about the
hate they get or things like that I
honestly feel like I'm very lucky I
haven't really had my you know sex be an
issue I kind of feel like I I've always
kind of blended in and even when I
didn't I just took it as inspiration to
get better and to prove that I can do
this I can gain I can do but as far as
the clap back stuff yeah I'm very I'm
very subtle but I do I do
yes my name is fitting because I'm Eric
cuts you know it just kind of played
perfectly yeah a little bit I can hold
my own you know I think I have thick
skin I think that's one thing that
helps me and sometimes I have to
remember you know when people get upset
about things I have to remember you
maybe my skin is a little thicker I need
to chill a little bit yeah because that
literally how you got the name so you
just explained that yeah you definitely
you could definitely hold y'all that's a
fact so yeah look what you done out here
so I got to ask you the question that we
ask every guest at the round table
I need lady Ericka's top five games or
franchises of all time oh man no Dark
Souls and gears gonna be in there so
should I put those two right away well
honestly top five five all-time them was
the most I had the most for you okay
definitely Legend of Zelda Zelda is that
I mean Ocarina of Time was was my
ultimate game for years and years so
yeah I love that franchise I really
don't you love Metroid as well I told
you I'm a Nintendo kid so I grew up on
Metroid's for Metroid was like yeah I
was like the first game i beat up be
good for you today I see okay here's I'd
say is in there I mean like I said is
what kind of brought me back to be more
hardcore again and I love the
multiplayer I can't wait for Gears 5
that's that's one I do love souls born
in general so it's hard for me to just
pick one I love blood-borne
I love neo I love I just love those
games so although let's say the entire
soul like the soul series will put any
beta yeah you can go ahead and do that
yeah yeah just throw from software in
there trying to think I'm sure I think
what else what else what else oh that's
tough because there's a lot of games
I've played but sometimes I don't play
the whole series or you know any means
so impacted you the most it had the most
impacted me the most
you okay I really loved Castlevania and
Contra growing up like I think that I
think that really influenced
to what I like now like with gears for
example you know after playing contra
you know I just love that like I love
shooters sometimes and I love that
sometimes that like dudebro stuff I
recently played vanquish and I loved it
I just loved it
we are Zelda we had Metroid we had the
Soul series we had yourself from
software yeah yeah yeah because I love
Metroidvania 's and that's you know
Metroid and Castlevania so yeah so get
into it oh great video games just
mystery by the way that was awesome all
right so long thanks it says Pole then
last week's poll results are in and the
people have spoken to the question with
the recent Mortal Kombat 11 reveal how
do you feel about the lack of
information or gameplay footage
regarding the Nintendo switch version at
the event the winner at 40% of the vote
very close by the way which was why ruin
a good event with a slide of downgraded
switch graphics a raise a close second
place opposite was the switch owners
will be treated the same as the Xbox one
and PlayStation 4 grow you know get back
in the bushes
I don't care unless we get that smash at
Mortal Kombat crossover we deserve
thanks to all the lords who participated
in last week's poll lady Erica what do
you feel about the attendance which that
being presented at the Mortal Kombat 11
reveal then reveal I don't honestly I
didn't even think about that I did watch
the reveal I'm not the biggest MK fan I
did play it growing up but I don't
really play fighters but you know what
it is though I think I'm just used to it
I feel like when it comes to these big
multi plaids the switch is kind of left
behind
I mean they all be having like a
different developer or something like
that
I read that yeah so I'm expecting this
thing you know it's probably it's
definitely not gonna look as good we all
kind of know yeah I guess I'm just used
to that you know Nintendo is kind of
like an asterisk at this point like oh
by the way it's on the switch premium
prices for subpar situation $65 if I'm
putting my switch game face on right now
I'm saying oh we're paying for the
portability already oh that's kinda like
but personally I mean I if I was by a
Mortal Kombat I I would not buy it on
the switch so you had no problem with
them not showing it so to speak I'd give
it like ruining the event because the
higher graphical versions were there the
presence of those graphics entire event
not Ronda Rousey out there pretending
this you like Mortal Kombat right that
enfold the event but but switch graphics
hashtag subpar situation but there's a
lot going on in in the anthem world so
we go get it to these topics man there's
a lot it is kind of hard for me to
believe there's a lot going on there
ain't no one playing break this thing
down into two parts and the first thing
I want to kind of get into was obviously
the VIP devil you know whether was
whether it was misleading so I'm
obviously you know we know let's frame
this this whole thing up you know we
know one of the lead directors I believe
his name was Mark Dhara and he had put a
tweet out so producers again this is
before the demo launched you know all
that stuff trying to get people
information I guess about what to expect
from the demo so he pretty much said
like house need a demo different from
the game and he goes we start from you
in the middle this tutorials
no pilot picker balance is super
different economy is completely
different and six weeks less bug fixes
right like tonin oh yeah why is there no
tutorial game which is like I do but
like and it's not even that was the most
suspect I'm just like why would you not
put a tutorial in an actual get the
actual game but you put it in the beta
it was very strange because a shot of
slum I think he experienced the Alpha as
well with me and then on the actual
alpha which I was in had a tutorial so
it was strange that they chose this
direction you know me so anyway they
continue all he could sit on he said
there's only one story arc I think that
uh he said the mission stronghold free
play balance will be off a bit he said
slightly less nuanced PC controls and he
renamed a few things for clarity in the
main game so let's just start with this
aspect right cuz obviously I mean I
believe Lord
fons really had a fantastic video up and
he was definitely talking about this
situation and he had issues with it you
know he had a lot of issues with it as
far as they're not on putting the demo
almost as far as the balance the economy
you know you can't really can hear me
the building sir yes I can
that's the small voice there we go there
we go mommy what main building let's go
so on pretty much right on time I was
just pretty much framing it we're
talking about the anthem VIP demo we
could talk about the first part of this
we're gonna break it in two parts one is
gonna be about the VIP demo then the
second is gonna be action about the demo
launch so they're just over the first
one we know we talked about mark Dora
the situation about how he outlined how
you know about what to expect from the
demo the economy different the balance
different and I talked literally about
you in reference to your video how
strongly you felt about it and disagreed
with what was going on and I just want
you to set it up and frame like your
video and how you feel about that
situation well balanced and excuse me by
the way I'm sick so I was under the
weather but I just wanted to say that
with this situation when I first read
that it said that the balance and the
economy were gonna be super different
like that to me stood out because I know
they do tweaks and some of these types
of games sometimes to try to make it
more enjoyable and stuff I don't like
this type of deception mm-hmm I think it
gives some gamers a false sense of
security with their purchase the key
with balance and economy these two
things people may just like let this fly
under the radar but these two things are
huge in a game like this especially the
balance part when you think about
balance in the game that is inherently
grindy which this game will be it's just
like a destiny type game it's a it's a
lunar you're gonna be going around
trying to get these lutes and you're
gonna grind for it so the balance is key
so what what kind of balance tweaks are
they doing here are they making it
easier and more enjoyable you know
that they entice some of the gamers that
may not launch grind per se right we've
already heard some gamers out there
saying it doesn't feel that grindy oh
wait
and then you over the economy aspect and
I've got people already in my comment
section to my video calling me out
saying it's only 25 coin for everything
mm-hmm but wait it's gonna be at least a
hundred two hundred maybe thousands for
these different items in the game it's
not going to be 25 coin people for the
demo right and the case in point I was
trying to put out there for people not
everybody's on Twitter not everybody
listening to what Martin my cards name
and and so there's gonna be a lot of
gamers duped when you're buying this
game thinking a it's not grindy and be a
it's not that expensive okay really good
no because they're gonna be selling you
these coins for $4.99 a pack or whatever
you know this stuff it's obvious and I
don't have a problem with that per say
hey it's microtransaction city with
gaming today well I get it but at the
same time and it is Cosmetics and I'm
good with that so oh we know it's cuz we
cosmetics and I'm good but the fact that
there is deception there within this
demo so you're categorizing that is
deception it is okay even if they tell
you like I said even if Martin mark Dora
says it or it doesn't mean oh they're
being completely completely transparent
with everybody
isn't that everybody reads Twitter
Street magic like you know you see the
magician on the street he's doing
everything right a Fermi's not a little
sleight of hand we still tricking you
you still be a tricked you get presented
the stuff right there in front of you
but they're telling you it's not gonna
be exactly what it is okay so so I got a
question for Fonz before I open
for everyone else too in reference to
that part too um what about in replicas
we do know there's a 2-1 VIP demo that
actually launched and then we know that
there's a free demo what do you say for
those that like I say like hey you know
if you're kind of on the fence with data
you feel this is suspect I just wait for
the second one as far as not dealing
with that first demo so well is the open
beta they're calling it they're not even
calling the open beta demo like become
VIP demo yes much to me and now this one
is going to be an open beta well what is
the open beta correct before it's
actually demo also they actually
actually rolling with the demo term
which is a bit it's gonna be essentially
the same game that you're playing now
right pretty much I mean we don't know
the details yet but I mean one if we
could assume we would assume yes and
then apparently what's more bug fixes to
come later at that point but who's to
say that it actually reaches that one so
it still to be determined but but I
don't you know I don't think there's
anything different between the two and
and also you know the economy and the
and the six weeks bug fixes and
everything it's all going to be the same
for this this open demo as well so I
mean I I don't I don't see you know I
think it's funny because I think the
bigger deception lies in what they
actually presented to us this week aside
from the balance in the economy when
they sent us this weekend was uttered or
in fonts trust me we go going just save
that thought I just would ask it I want
to get lady I don't Erica in on the VIP
demo aspect like what did you feel when
the news came out from Mark Dhara and
these guys about what the demo was going
to consist though I kind of thought of
it like well duh it's not gonna be you
know the main game but then you know
Fonzie brings up really good points cuz
like we're on Twitter I'm on Twitter
I'm on the know of these things and I
kind of I expect this game to be grindy
so when I play the demo I just thought
well I just want to get a feel for this
game I want to see
what it's like what it feels like to you
you know to fly to use those weapons and
the javelins and all of that so that's
how that's why I didn't really have any
outrage or any disgust like oh they're
tricking us it's like no I I know what
I'm getting into like I know this is
gonna be a looter I know that it's gonna
be compared to destiny and I didn't like
destiny everyone knows I didn't like it
so my whole thing was like I just want
to see if this is not like destiny if I
can get some kind of hints or anything
to know that maybe I could like this
game so when I heard oh it's gonna have
a different economy and it's like well
yeah I expect that because they want us
to get a feel for the different javelins
the different I know that that when I
unlocked a javelin after two missions
that's not happening in the main game
right but see that I'm in the know and
so far things look great that's a great
point with that yeah these casuals or
people who aren't on Twitter they're
thinking oh this might be the main game
this isn't destiny hey I might like this
you know and then they're gonna get
fooled so I'm sort of yeah it personally
didn't bother me but I do see yeah this
is kind of this new thing it really is
its EA after all it Lord solving here
I'm curious about his perspective when
the news came out about the VIP demo how
did you feel about it you know about a
dev basically stating that the balance
the economy would be different from you
know said what you call you know
finished product it doesn't make any
sense to me because we're too close to
launch for you not to have something
that's resembling the finished product
out there it doesn't make any sense and
as much as this game has to launch with
a lot of goodwill in order for it to
survive you want to put your best foot
forward and in doing that you're not
you're not doing that I mean there was
so much excitement coming out of the
Alpha from everybody who couldn't talk
about what they experienced me in any
right and then and then you have people
and then finally more people get to play
and they're like what's the big deal
and one one question I have for you is
what how do you how does it differ from
the alpha um I get it to it real quick I
want to get loo skin but uh yeah that's
different from from jump is obviously
yeah the way you upgrade stuff is a bit
faster a little bit faster as for my
main issue is the tutorial I felt like
the Alpha did a better job of explaining
how the gameplay mechanic is gonna work
and how basic things about the job
wasn't gonna work whereas the demo kind
of just drew you in and was like just go
ahead and it really wasn't enough
explanation I'm assuming that you had
played the alpha almost like that yeah
it was like this is from me I was fine
right because I knew about movement I
knew about this but I could put myself
in a mentality of someone who never
played and they're gonna be like okay
like trying to figure things out cuz I
even i put some footage up and someone
asked me on twitter like yo how did you
get your javelin hovered stationary like
that well so i imagine you know in a and
hover and also you just press there and
look so again i just go to show me they
didn't do the tutorial didn't do a good
job explaining it but continuous up yeah
I just I just think you're sort of
sabotage themselves a little bit because
now people just on the strength of small
things that again may in all likelihood
be vastly different in a month when the
game comes out but I mean Nate they're
formulating opinions based on those
things and they may or may not purchase
based on those things you have to be
sure to put your best foot forward with
this demo to make sure that the
excitement around the game after that
alpha continued and I just don't think
they've done that oh call first go you
know it's gonna be interesting to see
you know how it does when it launches
and how different it is from this
lord King VIP demo do you have an engine
I'm gonna mute my mic so you can't hear
me laugh and stare you want to go away
King um yeah go for it alright so hey
how many you guys Girl Scout cookies oh
god you don't analogy of Girl Scout
cookies cut right because I gotta hear
this
Girl Scout cookies all right so let's
say you go to your local Girl Scouts the
outside right they got they look Okies
and they say hey here's a sample of the
cookie not a game your cookie and they
put a little bit more flavor in app a
little more sets a little more pop right
but then you brought the box of Girl
Scout cookies and it ain't have that
zest and ain't had a pop mm-hmm
that's exactly what they're doing then
put a little bit more zest in it allow
you to do things a little bit quicker
have a little bit more pop probably have
a little bit more enemies there and made
it a little bit more fun ones are really
said that maybe it's a little bit more
fun maybe the game is boring and if they
gave you the actual representation of
the game and you'll be so turned off
from it you will purchase it hmm
so the fact that the matter is that they
told you they are Street magicians this
is what you see little change oh when
you get so what you're saying is they're
gonna get they're gonna be the seco and
now you can see me three exactly what
I'm gonna go in on because he was privy
to what really happened to me he was he
was there yeah oh by the way I just have
to correct something that I said earlier
one more point appointed it out in the
chat and I agree hundred percent he said
that I made the assumption that the the
open demos can be the same as the VIP
and yes that is an assumption by me and
I really think it probably will be most
likely but I I it's it's a definite
sumption that's not a fact fan-in and
also real quick on the same topic that I
just want to say that the the fact that
that I say that there is some deception
here doesn't mean that I'm saying that
the company is outright lying or
anything but in a lot of gamers Minds
again and not everybody reads Twitter
right there are people you can read in
my comments section folks that are
believing that the way the game is being
played now in this demo in the legit
game this is exactly how it's going to
be
with the economy balance everything and
that I agree with that part that
specific part I agree with you because
again like Lena Erika said like you said
not everyone reads Twitter right so you
know the masses that go to a Gamestop
over wherever all that gamestop but
you're not saying wherever they
pre-order or whatever you know they
might not be privy that information and
concede that that might be the case I
just want to get home addict and addict
you any table at the bit yeah just that
dot not the game launched just the VIP
demo information released all right
first off let me I kind of Ikes
I respect that they're being transparent
I didn't like but at the end of the day
it's like you could tell me all kinds
you could put a ribbon on it I mean you
you could put a golden ribbon on it have
some gold boxes like your publisher is
EA that's literally like you are
literally owned by the best
bait-and-switch in the business expect
me to believe you it's a demo everything
is ramped up to the tenth because they
want you to get stuff as a quick as
possible as accessible as possible
because they want you to play as much of
that demo as possible and if they make
you grind the way you were going to
grind in the actual game you ain't
getting none of that stuff mmm but at
the end of the day it's like when you
come out and use the word completely
mixed people it makes people sidestep
but it's like what what do you mean
completely I feel you on that language
I'll give you that
I feel you in their language they let me
jump it if you finish that I'm kissing I
feel like I feel better I feel like a
better way put it was like they should
have put on their since this is the demo
the actual economy in the real game is
gonna be different because that is the
long-term and this is no this is a big
old experiment it's a that he did he
what he said that with the response
after her people started backlash yeah
he didn't say that from the initial
response right but he literally followed
up minutes later well I was giving you
the perspective of avoiding this
absolutely let me jump in because I
gotta piss everybody off
all right look I would be really tough I
think this whole thing is overblown all
right let me tell you one specifically
the details of what's in the VIP look I
get it
big bad ei Battlefront - skepticism look
man I can't take anything you say after
you've been taking you you oh you bet on
that anthem juice it's no surprise you
or mr. project with the second part I
gotta say but the first part of just I'm
just not in agreement it's just like
here's the thing I don't have a problem
when the studio is literally telling me
for Batum what is going on in the demo
that I'm gonna get write to me I got a
problem like when destiny secretly
throttle the XP gang in a new body and
then they got caught already so it's
like it who to plague the demo and then
found out like yo how it was people that
play our game now I do math Oh God I
follow every Bioware developer stream
every tweet from the studio - the inking
this has probably been the most
transparent in my opinion regarding
what's in the demo and I'm saying then
not only did the VIP dudes they get
access they allow three and a moochin
friends to get in on action you know say
like to be like they didn't have to do
that so the other part I struggle with
is look I get it with the pre-order
aspect you know I'm saying if you don't
feel comfortable I get it no Sam my
thing is there's also a second free demo
on February 1st so if people are turned
off they say yo I'm not feeling that you
know I'm saying I'm not you know going
pre-order cool no one's pressuring you
to do anything the issue I just have is
just like it just did the tiki torch
stuff you don't say like it's like yo it
is Sado proven guilty
ready telling you what it did you know
it's like that's my thing
skepticism is cool I'm just not okay
with condemning something before it
launches like I'm just not with that
because that is the thing if
anthem if this was the Finnish game and
add them launch like halo Master Chief
collection now you could bring the tiki
torches out you can do whatever you want
but demos have always been a vertical
slice of gameplay that's been around for
years
so don't that
kind of me is gonna be a certain way and
it's gonna be speed ups just so you can
get unlock stuff later in the game so
you can feel how other Japanese I don't
got no problems with that you know but
here's the thing but here's the thing
like going back to destiny
when we first demo it was basically the
start of that game the game the actual
whole game Oh
and they didn't tweak anything nothing
was changed that started the full game
it so you knew right away what type of
game it was right like that you liked it
if he didn't he didn't I loved it so I
was all-in right game I'm side I in it
because a gonna be because it's super
different in in a couple of ways number
two its EA and I'm always gonna side I
get that hey listen farms on the EA part
I can't defend that right if you dealing
with someone if you if someone that you
love is best friends with someone who's
sheisty hanging out with that dude I
don't feel you on this is what's in the
box
does it about it's up to me to say you I
don't want your box fam end of the day
the best way to approach this is like
look okay I get like four people like
I'm right there with fawns you know I'm
very skeptical VA because I love
battlefront and they they they drop the
ball there so like I've gotten to the
point where I'm like you know I haven't
made one video on the matter
I haven't talked about it really on
Twitter cuz I'm like well I'm just gonna
way for the reviews care you come out
openly multiple times be Vegas how about
your rates I'm gonna wait for the rains
see what I think myself that's pretty
much what I want to see let's get into
the second part which is o which is the
actual demo itself you know saying
yeah yikes so obviously you know we know
what happened you know the game launched
and they will lot of issues you know
saying so um let's start from the people
who were able to go my first way is
anybody been able to get everyone in the
kind of able to get into the devil I saw
I played two missions I can't get into
the third okay so okay cool and then
Fonz you you I died so you know you got
in but it took a minute it wasn't all
about all the problems to you first
because already bill you go in it so far
it's like tell us about your experience
with the the launch of the all right
first of all I sat there for about about
four hours straight trying to log in I
was in the morning hanging out with
friends and stuff so it was fun you know
we made a party we're all trying to log
in none of us could get and finally
somebody got in soccer 87 and you know
he played for a few minutes and then I
believe he was he got into a frozen
screen or something and got booted and
he couldn't get back in and then finally
I just gave up and I came back six hours
later fought the fight again for another
couple hours about 10:00 p.m. at night
Friday night then we started to play
gotten to a loading screen just hung
there forever
it crashed out to the Xbox you know yeah
and I'm like okay alright and and so
finally I get in and I start to game a
little bit and I'm and I'm having fun
with it like I will say this about the
game the game itself is not bad like it
it's it's a fun game it's different it's
it is so different from I know it seems
onra is destiny okay it's a Loutre
shooter but it's different in the sense
that the combat is way different the
abilities and stuff are a lot more fun
than the abilities and stuff in destiny
because the primary focus of course in
destiny is the gunplay here it's more
about the abilities and everything and
your your group makeup is also
everything in this game and I and I like
that aspect and this is I was talking to
the soccer about this I really want this
type of gameplay I want a game like this
but again so I'm playing and we do a
stronghold me and a couple of buddies
we're going through the stronghold it
was an epic battle with this big giant
monster and we're like yeah this is fun
this is fun as soon as we beat this
thing
crash all we get nothing
you get win and we're sitting there
going what and then this other dude
jumps on for half an hour reads off for
half an hour mind you he's playing and
then he goes oh I finally unlocked my
next suit and I'm like what I've been
fighting for a couple of hours
I haven't unlocked again water this cave
with water and [ __ ] this wall and all
the sudden I go through the wall and I'm
a fly off into an you know an
everlasting freakin nothing for the
abyss and then again you know what's
gonna happen Fonz at the end of that
you're gonna pop out and you'll be in
destiny that point I hadn't shut it off
turn it back yo that's how Guardians
aboard that's that's the light couldn't
get back in I couldn't get back in oh
yeah I said you know what I had enough
on Friday night now I'll be back
tomorrow hopefully this this is messes
fixed I come back Saturday they're all
playing in there I mean there for two
hours trying to get it can't get in and
they're just laughing and I'm like dude
this game is a hot mess this demo is a
hot mess I've been there your friends
are laughs and it's just making you more
fear yes
I'm done I'll come back later four or
five hours later I come back I finally
get in like yeah this is cool all of a
sudden all this rubber banding and stuff
starts to happen I'm getting pulled pull
back and I'm like what so I log out try
to come back in now I can't get back in
again finally an hour or so I mean I'm
playing and enemies are disappearing at
once you wanna wait a minute this game
this game is a six week old build this
game is a six month all build this game
the six week old build me a fix
everything that's going on here before
it comes out in three weeks people
that's why that's my scary point that's
like where I'm like wait likes it's like
only a six week old bill in its weeks
can they can they prevent people from
crashing through walls can they prevent
stuff from disappearing and Houdini [ __ ]
and pop into are real it's beautiful
the gameplay is fun it's fast it's the
different javelins when I finally did
get my other javelins on the ps4 mind
you I was able to do that first I went
over there and I played over there for a
little bit and I'm telling you I got my
xbox got a different they're fun like
they're all naked different I like this
type of gameplay but its EA and they
just screw things up dammit and this has
got EA stank all over it this is not
game folks it may be a fun game but it
feels nothing like Bioware it has no
Bioware feeling to it at all it's just
all EA moneymakers there was no sort of
story at all and I mean like in the
Alpha there was more of a story there
like they didn't they didn't do it it's
about what again I wanna get later
because you know she had a stream she
had a yaks part three
okay so I played on the ps4 and the
loading screen time is real on ps4 I
don't know if it's like that everything
but I ended up kind of finding a little
trick with it cuz it would freeze all
the time on that loading screen so I
would close the application restart it
and then it would ask me if I want to
rejoin that matchmaking so I'd say yes
I'd say like half the time maybe 40% I
would get in and that's if I would stay
in there cuz yeah there would be
crashing there would be you know
teammates leaving or whatever and then
it would crash but yeah once we were in
and I was I was playing with randoms I
wasn't playing with friends or anything
else just playing randoms it wasn't bad
you know it was fun there's um some guns
I really like like the special weapon
that I had you know with the the Rockets
you can use those those were cool the
ground-pound you know like I really
liked it I thought it was alright but I
do agree like I didn't really feel
Bioware's presence too much possibly I'm
getting there yeah but like the gun but
like the gun sounds kind of maybe you
know I felt a little boiler but other
than that the hub felt empty the sound
effects felt kind of off I just felt
like this isn't a really good demo like
it's not really a good demonstration of
like what this game is really going to
be as far as like that action part of it
I felt like the sound was kind of off at
times like everything that was off in
the distance was really low to me that
kind of bothered it I don't know if
anyone had that yeah and it just I felt
like it it should have been more epic
than it was I guess you know who was
having a lot of issues of this Lord cut
oh it was it was Jonathan the anthem
painter he's like oh this is a beta I
never would have known they were making
fun of anthem aluminum lyrics like he
low-key was like I might not buy this
because of this demo like that's how bad
it was
yeah it wasn't too fun of an experience
I didn't really even try it tell the
evening on Friday because I saw on
Twitter everyone was having problems I
was like I'm not even gonna try it yeah
I was like I'm not wasting my time I
ain't got you know because I was playing
solo so I'm not gonna sit there forever
so yeah I tried that evening and it was
I mean if you saw my stream it was like
I got in and then I got out it was like
it's so short-lived when you're actually
in there because of the issues and the
problems and I didn't really have crazy
glitches I've been seeing screenshots of
like people floating and and stuff like
that my thing was more so like the
Poppins and just the sound effects I
felt like I don't know if that's
glitching or it's just me it's just me
not liking the sound effects I don't
know but overall I thought it was just
so short-lived I didn't even really have
an opinion and then I played on Saturday
a little bit more I got to get to that
second mission and I did actually unlock
what is it called what are the girl
again the other javelins yeah the
javelin sorry I keep wanting to say
Valkyrie for someone but yeah Gavilan
and I was like okay cool I actually did
something I unlocked something but I
always knew okay this the main game
might be a little slower than this I
might not unlock things as quickly
possibly so just to get a little taste
of it yeah I do think it's fun when it
works but of course I'm always gonna be
skeptical that it's gonna be very grindy
it's gonna be like destiny cuz I just
I'm not a destiny fan so I'm keeping my
expectations low and if I had to say if
I'm buying this or not I would say no
not right now because I need to see more
I need to feel more so I do have a
question for you real quick
do you think this demo hurt the height
for this game I say yes definitely um if
there was type because even before like
there's a lot of people like me just
skeptical so I don't feel like the hype
was crazy from what I was seeing but if
there was
yeah I'd say this does kill it a bit I
feel like most betas can hurt height but
most the time people are like it is a
beta you know but I feel like you know
with this particular one like you know
got people like big
John 77 like he he's not necessary he's
a hardcore gamer but he's not really on
Twitter he's not on any of these things
he doesn't see this information and to
him he's like look this is a beta but
this is like to my understanding I
haven't played it this is worse than
your typical beta when you have a real
beta right when you when you put a beta
out that you really want people you want
feedback from and and you want to have
time to be able to rectify the things
that people have opinions on in the beta
you don't put that out on three weeks
before the game actually launches that's
not a real beta the the demo the demo
naming convention works more because it
is three weeks out so you're not you're
not really gonna make a lot of changes
based on age that's early access exactly
so it's not this is this game much like
any other game of this type needs a real
beta a real beta where you go in there
and break it and and and and really find
what's wrong and give the devs time to
actually address this stuff this is not
it if you think in three weeks this
thing is gonna launch any smoother your
network you you don't you don't believe
there's any improvement that could
happen between us no it's um of course I
mean this of course like the server knew
yeah stuff they already knew was was was
gonna give them problems here and then
maybe they're not necessarily gonna let
you know that but they knew certain
stuff was gonna break and and they're
working on that already
so they yeah there's gonna be certain
stuff but it smooth is not something
that I would assume and the thing is to
well I just wanna say this real quick
the apologists you know there are they
are out there you're saying you know it
is like a beta they'll bring up other
games right well Call of Duty has issues
and destiny and it's like no not like
this I I've played I played the destiny
beta it was not like this right which is
what Fonz was saying right yeah I maybe
had one crash maybe yeah that was it
though or disconnection I should you're
right from this perspective the issue
with those babies even the division all
that came out just accessing it right
but once you got through the queue or
whatever it may be
the game the game fundamentally worked
this problem that we're seeing here
right is that the game is not even
working in infinite loading and all type
of stuff but I want to get Noahide King
on this did you get a chance to
experience the gosh VIP demo I got even
better demo first of all first of all
your ball slave use a fraud juice for
you like sub y'all good content in here
duplicate content creators in here too
um alright so I saw shout out to pop G
for allowing me to play the game why oh
good alright so death is on and Jeff saw
me on and he saw me trying to load up an
impossible you know anthem and I was
like I got a access let me hit that
alright um now I don't want y'all to
think me trippin is game yeah I do not
want to buy this game okay I'm gonna let
y'all know right now but I have to buy
this game because I told y'all I have to
play with the patreon subscribers if
think I ain't played grudgingly
I don't want to buy this game I this
game should burn in the bushes alright
and then I'm going to tell you why so
I'm at the loading screen and def was
like no I'll play with you
so def sent me to invite at the same
time def sent me to invite Fonzarelli
somebody invite and uh my text funds
really I was like yo my man you know
send me everybody first so I'm gonna
shoot over here and play with him now
knowing that its funds really is not in
the game okay because when we looked at
funds early his name it says out of suit
like walking around yeah everybody is
aadi soup that was stuck at the
we were the Subi's up the pocket you
know what I was doing I was trying to
get you to send me an invite just in
case you were in the game everybody kept
sending me invites a game that I'm
trying to get in and it went and I was
texting Cognito at the same time it was
happening and once I looked up it was
five minutes in then it was twenty
minutes then it was 45 minutes then it
was two hours mm-hmm and my level of
frustration got to the point that I
wanted to just break my control of it
because I said who the hell at EA mm
didn't know then everybody damn near the
world you have to assume everybody in
the world let's take all the surf is all
for Battlefield or whatever the hell
titanfall shut them down put the serve
result what is anthem they want to play
it away play titanfall well let's play
titanfall that day because they could
play anthem I said Jeff I say y'all
let's play some pop g just relieve this
tension get the sophomore so we play
some pub G so my stupid behind after did
everybody went away and at night I came
back I said let me I'm be slick when we
slide back up in this well I'm getting
ready for work I could have been really
freaking sleep I'm getting ready for
work and I'm like yeah that I left it I
left it trying to get in why I went to
work Wow I came back four hours later
incredible this is incredible I wish I
would have got home and a little robot
would have been standing there Judge
Amblin was waiting for me to jump in all
right it turned it off went to sleep
woke up first thing I said I'm gonna do
try this again
try it again got in the game
I said all right here we go right
it has absolutely the worst town that I
was sweating off this is slow yeah we're
talking bad ramose okay so all right all
right get past this all right much my
javelin is over there get in this
javelin now let's get to this misleading
crap the Microsoft showed on the screen
dudes jumped off the cliff like you know
how you playing a destiny and you go see
the follow cliff you jump off that's
what they did in the demo they jump off
the cliff
faster I'm gonna jump off the cliff no I
got cutscene and then my thing laying on
the floor like I am in I said literally
this is not what happened what they show
like this
Oh Froy oh yeah no tutorial man because
in the Detroit Alfa they actually showed
you that like they just threw you to the
wolves
I just feel like if you have a tutorial
in the Alfa but you're not putting in
the road game what was the point in
making a tutorial in the first place I
agree are they saying no to tour in the
final yes in the demo is no tutorial in
the final game there should be I thought
he said the difference between the demo
and the real game was that knowing the
Alpha in the real game I mean the demo
was that the Alpha had a tutorial did
demo did not let me say this right I
played the game and I know exactly what
they're gonna do as far as what funds
really was afraid of know what they're
gonna make them more bullet spongy like
they had in Division one all right um I
believe that's how they're gonna stretch
out a lot of things and they're gonna
make the grind a whole lot harder um if
I didn't have to buy this game I
wouldn't buy mm-hmm right but
graphically it looked good yes the
control was there on the javelins um
the shooter aspect it's not destiny
everybody knows destiny gun game is
second to none shooter the shooter
aspect of it was passable it was better
than the
shoot aspect when I first played
division and I really liked division
yeah alright so but then the world with
the no direction with the null
explaining anything to you and just
saying like have at it I think that was
the wrong way and wrong choice and
presenting the demo to the public that
is skeptical skeptical already which a
product so I think people are going to
be turned off completely whoever got
into the game is gonna probably be
turned off completely from the game and
don't purchase the game because it was a
poorly implemented demo that hurt the
sales that is getting coming forward
which I think these did the game really
need everything to go right thing from
demo to to presentation to messaging to
everything needed to go right for this
game and I really think this took the
wind out of this is because everybody
start playing Resident Evil or something
else yeah nothing I feel let me let me
jump in me um yeah that this part I am
1,000% with Laura Fox demo launch you
know what's funny 24 an hour ago to
myself of like with this demo Lord all I
could think about was the Bungie offices
they like huh you want a bit you want to
launch a car soluti shooter reference
for that but they'll be there's
definitely major inexperience shown here
Lavar work well is their first attempt
at the shower this is definitely a beast
different be from trying to launch Mass
Effect or some type of dragon any type
of game you know I'm not gonna sugarcoat
the the launch was awful like it was no
this we can't get around it like I know
my people were five to six hours trying
to wait to get in you know shout the low
whiskey we weren't able to get in I kind
of deal with Erica did which was once I
saw the reports coming out I said all
right I'm not even gonna attempt it
because I know how console mmo's go
right a little shoot is that first
couple of hours I'm like you know what
they gonna had a issues they're probably
queuing up I'll wait till later tonight
I'll jump in later came
there was no jump in the same situation
loading and they were pissed me off
addict was like like you'll be at the
loading screen it'd be like connecting
and then it doesn't say anything anymore
and you just sit there so you like am I
supposed to still wait and then like an
hour come by you gotta like hard stop
and quit the game and the one situation
like when I was in it it was me a man a
couple other people I'm gonna and
sinister I'm in an Xbox Live party chat
the game kicked me out of party chat and
forced me in a room by myself where I
can talk it about it
I couldn't press the Xbox Live button to
get out like to pull up my friends list
but nothing like I literally had to
hot/cold boom my system just to escape
the game I was like yo what's going on
here like that's crazy you know say now
I want a shout-out on Lord hole he got
the latest as latest episode of our
virtual Gotti is outstanding because we
are in agreement with this part the
product really got a problem though is
the statement to statement after the
fact I think it was on not that Casey
but their live team guy Chad whatever
Robertson and he made some three-point
statements and the giant was like soft
it was the most super defensive
statement I've ever seen for a bad
launch right your man is like yeah you
know the platform connections and yadda
yadda yadda but you know it wasn't us it
wasn't not for because we had the
servers you know you know this that kind
of thing it was like super defensive
than the entitlements with some people
that did have access to the VIP demo but
the game was telling you don't use not
and then the infinite loading they like
yeah we're gonna do these are
server-side patching and they the way
they acted is like you know just some
people are experiencing it yeah you know
I thought the same thing kognito because
I read that and I was like they said
some people had no issues at all and I'm
like who like it's just a small subset
of people that's it's positive so the
joint I had me tight is like yeah we had
our problems you know but it's
incredibly humbling to see all the
people playing over 300 K you know
Twitter concurrent users and we reached
fortnight numbers nobody's trying to
hear that right now for like map
who can't get into the game you know
saying so then the ultimate disrespect
in my opinion you've already wasted
people's time on Friday right basically
Friday was a dump 20 almost 24 hours
lost most people could not get into the
game then that statement is this cause
we appreciate everyone's patience you
know and sincerely apologize for those
trying to get into the game not getting
into game as a token of our appreciation
you know we're gonna give everyone who
participated in the VIP demo an
additional vinyl at launch nobody wants
your vinyls your demo for a game right
and then I had this other excuse where
it's like well you know in order to fix
the problem we would have had to shut it
down and we really will do that for the
people that was in there like you can't
do that so just when I was defending
your with the VIP joint now I felt the
EA snake now I like brûlées happen
everybody else was or twist and how fire
was weary for nobody wasn't it that
people cannot get into this game you
gotta address that and it was just a
very different sense half-hearted thing
man I think what people understand
because I see a lot of people even in
this chat and that I've talked to that
we're defending anthem to no end like
it's just it's just a beta guys come on
you're you're entitled no you got to
understand the level of frustration when
you're trying to get into this demo beta
whatever you want to call it right when
frustration is already through the roof
and then you know you got EA on top of
that so you got that EA stank on top of
it as you [ __ ] they're doing this you
know and in so a lot of us are legit bad
because it just won't work and we want
to experience this game you know we get
in and you play the game it's great
great that's the I I have to say that
because a lot of people think I'm hating
right I'm hitting on this VIP demo yes
I'm not hating I feel like you're eight
on the game I feel like you're hating on
yay and that's perfectly acceptable like
the game itself is beautiful the game
has a lot that King I really think when
you can actually cut again give it a
shot it there's a lot of great elements
in the game it it's it's really a great
game and it's not apart so far away from
destiny in terms of gameplay that I
think it's gonna do great right destiny
and and and I think it'll give destiny a
run for sure if it all works well if
they can get their act together here
yeah but that's the question I have for
you guys like day one dude I'm not look
I'm gonna end up buying this game okay
good I like it
but day one I mean let me just talk
about the game itself did you actually
be some good point cuz that's the sad
part about all this like but all let's
get lost is the game itself like I was
blown away like that you already seen I
put it up the movement the rotocaddy the
abilities you know I'm saying like I
finally got pcs even lit - I did both
for the XNA PC core gameplay is there
and what I like is like you said so far
like each javelin feels different unique
that kind of thing you know I do got
some issues though like that like they
cut that hole like you can't swap like
you can't go into your loadout in the
ludus shooter in the middle of a mission
about okay you pick up loot and you
don't got until the end of the thing and
it's like man why can't I just say I
actually saw some complaint nothing on
Twitter they're like we want to get
drops the whole throughout the whole
thing not at the very like my thing is
the problem that lady Erica because I
watched her stream which was like they
think I don't like is if you go down
it's just a wrap like you just and it's
funny too because like it tells you a
countdown that you could respond but you
can't respond you can't like literally
and if your plans don't load you got a
hope the randos and the blueberries are
come over to your body and pig otherwise
that's your experience for the whole
night you're just gonna stay there
that's not that happens a lot when
you're playing with randoms you just sit
there dead and nobody will come get you
I gotta mention something on the loading
screens I'm talking about within the hub
worlds like why how many loading screens
in a hub world it's a lot it's low into
a hub world and then you go to a cave
loading screen you come out of the cave
loading screen all right no 30 okay you
go to free play I know how you can
access a loading screen right away 30
seconds you you you jump right off the
ledge there right at the free play start
go to the left you fly for like 20 30
seconds loading screen and then you go
to like part of the whole world it's
like why this is the hub world have
loading screens within world now I
wouldn't just serve that fast excited
checks actually been a good point you
know I'm saying yo slow mo said he got a
loading screen of the building combat
I'm done
oh but now a fact like he said I get the
EI hate but by wait has a great history
get the benefit out the problem is they
kind of messing up the benefit of the
doubt after the fact with the statements
the way they're handling it that's my
main issue you can't tell people that
paid for a VIP access demo well just
some of y'all was experienced but
everybody else was lit like you can't do
that you can't get the message in seem a
little EAH to me and that mad donut when
they tell you oh there are some people
that we're getting in with no problems
you're like eff those people you know
and I paid you know I'm saying I paid
for the oranges or I paid for the thing
so that's my main thing but as far as me
what's your question for us with the day
one you know I'm gonna get I still know
the game I'm going to get the game well
yeah he's concerned this this definitely
is a major blow to their marketing a
major blow to the hype that was drawn
and I know a lot of people that because
of what happened is like nope not doing
it you know so anybody that it that
hates our destiny because it's grindy
but they're loving anthem like hype a
game when it comes to that genre it's a
lunar shooter that's you're gonna be
grinding
both games so if you one reason why you
didn't like destiny and you're not gonna
like anthem so you're just gonna waste
your $60 you got anything on this before
you or I was just gonna say you know I
didn't like destiny so yeah I agree with
funds that's why I'm gonna wait and you
know if there's any differences that
would matter and make my experience
better you know what I mean so anybody
loves the game if any words on his
Frick's skeptical in a face and I love
Bioware so it's like yeah but let's move
what Lord King got the hottest topic in
the realm right now man yeah this is
probably gonna take the rest apart yeah
like you got the hottest boy everybody
we were not gonna do this topic and then
when we found out what King brought it
to the table everybody was like yo we
don't care King got it I was like I'll
drop my topic Saavik no reason not to do
this topic like like smoke let's go like
social of going okay ruffle a lot of
feathers is gonna hurt a lot of
companies feelings and maybe they're
gonna look at me a little bit different
right now but what I don't like and it's
going on it's not just the streamers
it's all content creators that actually
spend hours upon hours because I listen
to them this they spent hours and making
their videos and putting their content
up and they're streaming and they're
working very hard and doing this stuff
right and but you have these companies
that grab ahold of the content creators
they're influencers you have 10,000
followers and when you say something
your followers listen if you got 10% or
1% of your followers they actually
listen or whatever you say and go
purchase something based on your
recommendation or based on your videos
or based on something that you did and
it is that a benefit for a company then
you just did marketing for this company
and um when you do marketing for a
company these people that's on that
marketing team that gets paid that's not
doing what you're doing your act
moving units so what companies are doing
and I've noticed that the reason why
this came to me is because a fellow
podcast of mine told me a company made a
discord and had a lot of influences
inside the discord I was giving out like
key codes and stuff like that today game
mm-hmm and they were he was very excited
he was very happy with it and I said why
are you happy with it he said oh man I'm
in the know I'm in mm-hmm I said this
company has millions of dollars for a
marketing team what this marketing team
did was actually giving you something
that didn't cost them a penny because
they put up a digital code and gave it
to you and um you're going to put out
the video and you're gonna show for the
video and you're gonna influence the
game and you're gonna push the game and
the marketing team is gonna do very
little but those marketing dollars and
these CEOs is getting 15 million dollars
bonuses and stuff like that and mmm the
influencers are getting flown out to
companies because I heard some
influences got a bag number they have
seven did that fall out 76 bag the day
actually got a real bag right and you
fly them out on very next to nothing
they're happy to get it around you give
them a little dinner and you show them a
little reel and they go back and they
work 20 hours on your video if a company
is gonna start flying influence us out
and they're gonna start acknowledging
these influences put them on payroll put
them on payroll put them on your
marketing team see because what you're
doing is free labor
if Tommy comes in Moseman I love to hit
of the block and I give them a cookie
and I don't pay him I'm a bad guy mm-hmm
you understand
the practices that are being practiced
on these youtubers these influencers
these streamers and these guys are not
getting a check
you're not even sending them a PC or
software of something that can equal the
amount of hard work that they're putting
in for this content and movie units are
talking to their fans to get them riled
up for your product but you fly them out
so you acknowledging them at that point
but you're not acknowledging that you're
using them and not compensating them for
their hard work and you're giving them
pittance and I don't think that that
practice should continue mmm this is a
hot one so I'm gonna get I want to get
attic first cuz I know he's got limited
time and I know he's gotta go to work
and stuff but I want to get addict then
we get at Eric and Fon so you know what
addict this is a touchy one so let's get
to it man is does King have a point here
do our devs taking advantage of problem
second advantage of youtubers is that
free labor should youtubers and
streamers get paid for this level of
promotion that they I think when it
comes down to it is I think they they go
off what your reach is mm-hm
because I know for a fact that if you
got a decent decent reach and they
sponsor your videos you getting paid but
the question is is like it doesn't even
own people that's had like fifty sixty
thousand subscribers and they just get a
review code you know they give you the
thing is is like I agree with King put
than I disagree with King came because I
do believe that you know to a point that
they're taking advantage of the smaller
into the middle channels and they're
putting the majority of the money for
the big big channels like your
PewDiePie's he getting paid he ain't
doing nothing without getting a check I
guarantee you that but like you know
they if you have a reach having that
content early can it is very very very
beneficial
like almost every video that I've done
that has gotten traction that's got me
subscribers it's gotten me viewers Shh
has been a review code from someone that
didn't pay me because you're supposed to
take the content that they give you that
they've privileged you with because
technically you don't have to do that
and make content before anyone else on
YouTube and put it out there cuz Kingdom
Hearts 3 the people the people because
I've been in talks with the people
that's been distributed in North America
they got 500 copies that means out of
the thousands upon thousands of channels
on YouTube 500 people got a review copy
in North America so I mean if you add
the other regions maybe maybe a hundred
you know because I know North America is
one of the biggest regions they give
them a lot more so I know people there's
there's a channel called gamer joint
he's nothing but Kingdom Hearts he
didn't even get a review copy right so
that's what the and it's like I said I
do think that you know they need to take
a little bit more advance they need to
stop taking advantage of the people in
the middle but I know a couple of people
that you know they got flown out and
they and they gave them because they had
a job and they gave them the money that
they would have missed out flying out
there so they do try to attribute to
something but you know what's funny you
know who does stuff like this who does
give you buddy stuff like this is the
people people hey they EA that I think
I'm definitely gonna piggyback off of
addict I do agree it depends on the
reach like if someone reaches out to me
right now and wants to give me a free
game I am excited because I know that
I'm gonna grow and that I have one
example where I had a Dark Souls 3 a
little bit early and that did really
well on my channel it helped my channel
and I was little at the time maybe two
thousand three thousand subs maybe
mm-hmm and then now you know it just it
kind of gave me that boost so I'd argue
that for channels like me or even a
little bit bigger it it's benefiting us
a lot
it rather we get money or not we're
gonna get money in a
other way or we're gonna get views and
stuff like that but yeah if you're if
you're a PewDiePie or if you're a summit
have you guys know summit on twitch
eating you know thieves like crazy and I
was wondering cuz I follow him I like
him and I was wondering did Microsoft
that middle ground they you know if
they're not getting paid by people on my
channel like the 1520 thousand blows
like they ain't paying us to do nothing
okay for free but like you know we could
take that game a week a try something
you know we might be able to make the
money that game would have gave us
depending on how you know how much time
we put into those videos but those
people in the middle ranges I know
people that got 20,000 subs that can pop
out a review like look at that pop out a
review get like fifty sixty thousand
views and then that's pretty much a
couple that that's that's a decent
amount of money mm-hmm yeah and
especially if it's a you know because it
goes by ad revenue I mean you have a 20
minute video with two two ads it starts
adding up fast and because the only
reason they were able to do that is
because they gave them the game early
yeah and not only that but there's other
benefits too like your resumes being
built as a reviewer as a content creator
and so other developers may be looking
at you afterwards and you might get more
games you know what I mean so there's
other benefits that could happen but
yeah free game right you're not paying
for especially if you really want I did
that game and it's like hey this free
game you'd have to pay the 60 bucks or
whatever it was so you know in a way
you're kind of getting compensated
marketing it's not doing a damn thing
that I'm doing water but Tony worked
their whole year for a salary you want
50 videos that had it up to what Tony
did and Tony didn't do crap Tony off the
team Jimmy Tony spot but Tony's the one
that gave you the code
I was just gonna say you know if it is
the bigger guys out there they're being
flown out they're being used in
commercials things like that they I
think should get paid because they're
out they're out five hundred thousand
subs and above you getting a bag every
time you do anything
at they are we're not gonna know that I
can say nothing but they probably yeah
I think there was a statistic that
happened a couple years ago that like
the average twitch streamer that's like
anywhere on like the higher levels they
make like fourteen thousand dollars
every time they stream something that's
a sponsored video oh wow lord funds how
do you feel about if Deb's taking
advantage of youtubers free labor people
should people get be getting paid well
yeah with this
mmm-hmm i I feel like they do some of
the bigger ones anyway
I think with being flown out to places
all accommodations paid forward and
everything they're getting they're
getting that free vacation you know what
I'm saying
so I mean it happens and they already do
in a lot of ways when you're looking at
smaller content creators like myself if
you give me a free game I'm a cheap
bastard I will I will peddle your wares
as long as I will pretend to like see if
Neves for that all right just for a few
minutes
yeah Abington and Ericka here said I
mean yeah it's it that's the way it's
going now I mean all these big youtubers
and stuff they're getting they're
getting that you know cheese they're
getting it
they're good know act like they're not
gonna lie if Microsoft hit me of Lehane
something positive about crackdown 3 so
hard are you saying that you could be
bought my team is like here's a little
bag man like you don't even have to be
that big he's like he's a little bag
like you know say something balls about
the switch I'd like did the switch the
best thing that's my primary console
right now I don't know why anyone talks
snap about this like this is like I love
this look at a get paid off for the
review as a job it's really cold like an
investment that works for you to grow
your channel or in other creative ways
is wealth building Lord saw I'm gonna
soapbox this one man I'm gonna take it
from another angle
I think um you know the stuff the kink
talking about getting paid and whatnot I
mean this one word and nobody has talked
about here to this moment ever be yeah
that's the word when I got this topic
and I started this topic I know exactly
where you go a big ass word and I tell
you why the way of the world right now
when it comes to talking about video
games is increasingly YouTube it's
increasingly smaller channels individual
people with their own perspectives on
things that are not associated with any
sort of
big outlet and that's great the moment
you start breaking that down and taking
sides and and accepting you know
whatever money or whatever for your
opinions that completely breaks down and
the problem with that is that like I
said this is the future so if at his
core you start to break that down from
now and I'm not saying that there aren't
people who are doing it already right
there obviously people who are doing it
already that breaks down the entire
thing and for me it just doesn't make
your sort of auto-destruct in yourself
you're sort of self-destruct my problem
is the integrity that's a weird way to
say pronounce the word bills you know
let's say that you're a channel that's
like you know on the uprise and people
see that and you're still you know you
you you're not really people see that
you're grown but you're not
comprehending it yourself you know what
I'm saying
so you'll be sitting there and then
someone sends you like it's like I told
kognito I was like dude it's korrina's
hit me up and they're like we'll give
you a review copy for Kingdom Hearts but
you got to say this exact sentence that
we know Kofi is grown at like 1,400 subs
in three days give me that what you want
me to say so it's got a point if you
know everything is a big thing but you
know you see some of these youtubers
I've seen some of the big ones they they
might talk about a product on their
channel and they'll say and they're and
I'm being paid to say this blah blah
blah but I really do like the product
and stuff and then you never hear about
it again so you're like sure you really
like that product not generalize I mean
I say a lot of use it some for some
people the point of doing this stuff
besides your love of games is right at
some point you want to start making
money off of it right a decent amount of
money off of it so I get the money ass
picked away but if you if you look at
yourself and remember in the trade-off
is uh Marty my opinions my real opinions
for money and have everyone see me in
that light hmm
I go with integrity every time if you
really want to make if you really want
to be known years from now as somebody
whose opinions people respect mmm
when it comes to games when it comes to
the business around games when it comes
to anything that we're talking about
today that's not something that you
would do because it's gonna come back to
bite you it's not like it's not gonna be
there it'll come back tonight at some
point in time right so let's say you got
a review for a get like but your boss
says you got a key bag Keyblade and your
backup square-enix drop the bag off I do
man I'm not even joking with this man
there's very few games I will sell out
on it Kingdom Hearts is one of people
you will drop it like it's a fricative
okay okay let's say you get a review
code no sovereign for something like
anthem I know okay we're gonna give you
this review code but you can't talk
about certain sections of the game at
all
they say Splinter Cell because he's
assisting yes well just know you can't
talk about related to this you can't
talk about the story because there's a
lot of MPD's MBAs that will do that they
will tell you you cannot talk about
stuff acts if you tell me you just wait
you just said a review and I can't talk
about the story that doesn't make any
sense well you got I was giving you an
example they are certain story aspects
you know stuff that could actually
impact the review and overall right
right so if you're not allowed to talk
about that and you don't bring it up
would you take the review cause that
could that's kind of selling out there
like you can't talk about certain things
but you can review this game and you've
been waiting for a splinter stuff for
five years you gonna tighten up I'm not
taking that go if you tell me that
you've given me a review code the game
is complete and I can't talk about every
aspect of the game I'm like what do you
hear is a lot of door
have criteria okay you are a better man
than me you know I've noticed like the
people that you know are on like you
know oh I wouldn't do that I wouldn't do
that you're not the ones that's actually
reaching out to these people because you
don't review stuff like that like take
it from like Maya and Erica's
perspective like I've been doing a
channel since 2013 man like you be
sitting there be like man you know I get
that one break in the paper give you
that one break yeah potentially perfect
got um he was speaking to Cognito about
doing the videos right and the best
thing that I heard this man say was I'll
do the reviews but can I be honest about
it yeah thanks I want you to I want you
to speak on it I not disrespectful
manner but just be truthful though was
the I've been I've been I've been shown
MBAs that tell you can't talk about the
multiplayer no let me clarify that one
point cuz the scenario you Gator saw I
kind of agree with what solve is saying
and once aspect that most gay if they
give you a review cold then at that
point it should be a finished product
and you should it should be fair game as
opposed to let's just say they give you
early access you know this is your first
time footage of seeing said game and
they say okay you can't talk about this
and this just yet alright then I would
completely understand I agree we're
attic like I'm cool with that aspect
like you're not allowing up they're not
ready to discuss the endgame they're not
ready to discuss its portion tips and
I've sold myself for less
NDA's right where it's like for a
limited time you can't know certain
things but eventually you can yeah every
India has a day you know I don't wanna
probably NDA pertaining to early preview
access footage of a game right that
comes with the territory because they
want to control the marketing they want
to control how it's gonna be
disseminated on certain aspects that
they're not ready to talk about I'm cool
with that
but if it's a review now the game is
finished it's cold
they send solve the new Splinter Cell
review it didn't tell solve he can't
talk about this then not that's a
problem like in my opinion how could you
know it no you tell me are you I can't
spoil stuff that's one thing yeah that
talk generally about how I felt about
the story I won't spoil anything and I
mean into again exactly that absolutely
makes sense
but if you tell me no you can't speak
about this aspect of the store you can't
speak generally about what you felt
about the story in a review that doesn't
make sense to me if you ever see a paid
promotion game thing on my channel like
I was being very very new have you ever
do just hit me up in the DM z-- and I'll
let you know the real story you see me
review like you know Call of Duty's know
IBM pay your review ant there was a
division know I'm being paid to I got
the back
vote for them to get me to say yeah I
take that Mortal Kombat's which I mean
think about us on the podcast when we
are when we got that that Plantronics up
sort of with the situation right and
then you know wouldn't send you these
headsets and you just have to be sure to
put up a review on the site it doesn't
mean you know however you feel about it
you put it up so I'm like I'm do they
really mean that because if I don't like
the headset I'm gonna say wow everything
is great but it doesn't come with an NDA
would look like for Kojima's game it's
it's literally something you sign and
then you get sent to like a different
realm and they make you sign a bunch of
other [ __ ] you gotta sign it in blood
for the right size bag I'm 76 was the
best-case scenario is you you get the
bag for a game you actually like and
then you know you can say what you want
to say if they let you have freedom no
you're gonna you know anything about a
scenario and I'm II don't listen if you
want - Marcus is not taking do what
thirty dollars is gonna do what you
don't do but i'ma tell you not me I feel
right now I'm not me because at the end
and that's why you weren't getting a bag
that's what Tony didn't come from the
hard work and when I do say something
that somebody says yo Laker somebody
just said it in any chat um I value your
opinion and I don't want to see you like
working at IGN and some shield mm-hmm
and I know I'm gonna take the job I'm
not gonna dumb down my opinion because
of that bag let me jump in because I see
what you don't like listen it's fur this
is a fantastic table that we did it
because we've been put it off and on I
think it's a two-way street like we're
down or the publisher listen let me fit
in we're deaf like a devil publisher
they looking for the most exposure right
and I hate bacon cos we get out of a new
release or whatever and then you got the
YouTube stream Oh who's looking for the
most exposure and monetization to their
platform so to me where gets tricky if
the dev pays to youtuber because it's
like the job itself is not wrong however
to me I kind of struggle with paid
influencer because at the end of the day
it's like you got what are you listening
to that person review party is gonna be
like oh is they've been coerced to say
yeah positive stuff about said game
that's why I respect those that come out
and say yo so just pay for my flight
such as did this I just wanna let y'all
know you know I'm saying like this is
how this went down and I got it like
this so you could take it how you want
it at that point to me I don't know how
to handle exactly but no to me one of
the places that I think was that kind of
like the right answer was actually what
Bungie did and like what they did was I
think it's right around the time destiny
to the vanilla was you know that the
player base is dwindling you know I'm
saying everything was going down and
basically the devs held the summit where
they grabbed all the biggest youtubers
from destiny like the dados hopes man
all these dudes
yep they flew
these dudes in right and they say yo we
want your input on how to turn this game
around and they were giving out three
month paid contracts working for Bungie
there you go
so it's like now you like okay boom
you're the weapon tester modeling game
i'm holtzman you delivery tester myelin
games you gonna have you working on
stories doing that anytime no apparently
they're gonna do another convention I
don't know if they're gonna pay them a
whole glow and the building was gonna
love it but good to see you brother
virtual legality so it's like at this
point I think it's one of those
situations where is like if you you
construct the three-month contract or
something that effect when it's a paid
situation and they're getting direct
influence from their biggest youtubers I
like that I do agree with King in the
sense that yo you know people are
promoting these games and working very
hard you know I mean if they offer them
an opportunity I don't have a problem
with that it's just the whole idea of
hey if you're a paid guy under payroll
on your youtuber and the streamer now
that kind of has to be stated because
people gonna look at you with the side
eye that oh yeah this one he worked for
back division oh yeah this one he worked
for yay so we don't know how to feel
about said opinion but I'll give it back
the King let you finish out your at your
topic well we just noticed that by
having open dialogue that I really
honestly don't believe a lot of people
suffer at it is going to you know soul a
soul and be um how can I say I just know
a lot of guys aren't on that wave know
and I want people to understand you know
that this podcast with this team I knew
sovereign was gonna take that way with
it I knew it because this man has shown
nothing but integrity ever since the
moment I've met him back so I knew that
he was gonna stand up on like I said
that's so [ __ ] he was gonna rain it
down on you and give you real and I can
stand by him and say that definitely
true he's not gonna do it
he's not gonna you know take his opinion
and let it be worth nothing by taking a
bag for it
Tainted hmm so I appreciate that your
guys allowed to come on I appreciate
Erica because we presented it to you
first because I didn't want to put a
topic like this up and you uh you know
like get ambushed felt like yous
ambushed and topic and you know ambushed
in YouTube or any streamer where I
really appreciate your comment in
earphones like the female you guys are
both cats great content and we knew this
was a sensitive issue so we wasn't gonna
do it but I'm so glad we did it because
if to all the companies out there that
want a good review for whatever game
just hit me up for certain bag like if
you would have put a number to it oh no
no what um do you guys got you guys who
get um codes and stuff like that yeah
for for finished games do you get the
sense that they're asking you to sort of
direct your opinions a certain way or
they sort of giving you the game yeah
with the air they give you the game with
with the belief sort of that all press
is good press all I got a lot of players
that go you can be respectful but they
want you to they don't mind if you talk
negative about their game but they want
you to spin it in a positive way is
trash and that's it yeah I didn't see
that at all I talked to several
youtubers that you know bigger than me
and they get free [ __ ] but anyway they
told me that these some a lot of indie
developers especially they were their
product and they didn't tell them to
spin it anyway
no I'm not referring to them telling you
something I'm referring you hitting them
up six months later for another product
and they don't hit you back up people
not them but review games what have you
ever seen them talk about something and
a completely negative one let's let's
let's put it out there
let's go cuz he's a friend of the show
we don't okay with a hundred 100 right
now let's talk about rate law our friend
Lord caucus right and we know we're big
destiny guys and when he first started
out he was very fond oh he was very full
it again like you know like every time
there was a mess up by monji he was the
first to be on Front Street and I know
for a fact he was not invited to a lot
of these you know reveal events and
launch events and you know he continued
his grind on doing him and he ended up
being to the point where he got so big
they couldn't deny him no more you know
saying like he they had to include him
as part of that core community I'm
saying so again I get what people are
going as far as my experience falls with
that whole you know when it because I do
experience you know I get colds and
stuff like that to that nature you know
I never get told by a dev hey speak on
it this way or do it that way or that
kind of stuff it's just like hey the
embargo is here you know I mean you know
just you're allowed to stream or you're
allowed to do this at this date kind of
a deal I I've never been put in a
situation where you know you can now two
addicts point do I do agree with this I
have seen times that if there is it's a
big enough game and you are completely
transparent and brutally honest with
something that you do not like or you
rip it yeah I'm saying I've seen
situations where like the next time that
company's next release come up you not
at the top of the list family you know
I'm saying I I've seen and that that's
the risk you have to run and that's the
question you have to ask and that's why
you see integrity worth because that
could be a result of you going in on
something said that's the reason you see
a lot of these big reviewers you know
that's why you you read their comment
sections you look like all you didn't
really go in on this you don't really
going on that
especially when it comes to these
publishers people don't realize you know
when you review and triple a products
you got like four outlets of publishers
and once you barn bridges will fall for
this you done you monster shut your
channel down cuz you ain't getting crazy
thing I'm gonna push it back to you if
it's a game that you love and like like
Kingdom Hearts or whatever it is right
and you get it and they destroy our
aspect of the game that you love and
it's that you just heartbroken like by
kind of like what happened with fallout
4 and you were like yo it's or very
light version it's not fallout 3 it's
not New Vegas right and you go in on
that you know I'm saying like are you
gonna are you gonna curb your speech or
something that you're passionate about
because you're worried and that's cool
it's okay you talk about stuff but it's
like I said it's how you were really
preach that's what we're telling like
people don't realize this like I have
friends that you know they reviewed
triple-a products as rage that like if
you say the wrong sins
it could they'd blacklist you preach and
again not to put rants vinaigrette on
the show like what happened
he had no with the crackdown situation
he was like yeah maybe I should have
said it was a dumpster fire all about I
was talking around there like you
getting that crackdown review he's like
probably not because but don't get me
wrong I was proud of ran for keeping it
a buck on how they marketed that game
initially to those people who didn't
even play video games and which is just
playing crackdown in a very bad fashion
so I wasn't mad at what he did but I
understand maybe his wording on how hard
he went in affected now a future review
or cold or what happened there's like a
fine a fine line either wording
it's just so important like if it was me
I'd probably just be so slick and have
like backhanded compliments and things
like that I feel like you know where you
get my drift but it's definitely about
warning artists and giving context for
your opinions if you say something
chuck's tell me why and break it down
and if you break it down properly I have
no issue with you saying something
that me personally but would never ever
stay something sucks in a video like in
a review like that you really really
have to defend it you and I would wore
it like you know I was disappointed
unfortunately oh yeah I would like yeah
this [ __ ] yeah you know what the
greatest thing about it is King I work
for DISH Network I know how to corporate
talk now yeah but whether they call you
or you were not allowed to say
unfortunately you had a word around that
word like they would jump on you if you
said he's right he's right
hey my company they try to play that
game is this fanatical support game you
know you're not allowed to say certain
words and they can't know it yeah the
only apologize they told us to dis never
apologize either because when you
apologize you ship them plain to you and
not exact right that means you are in
fault mmm King this is a fire time we
got to move don't we get the best Louis
the funny thing is it that addict thinks
I was taking this topic as a glow topic
for Nintendo right to be perfectly
honest you gonna change I just let you
rock with that because I could care less
about the console sales like to me I
knew Nintendo was gonna win something
coming down the pipeline and I knew when
you said to me
King hold up hold up I knew I knew
Cognito and I never took that bet cuz
that's a stupid bet to take us but we
know not to take bets with King first of
all that's not good way to go so we
didn't take that bet so I don't worry
about that
but for me the best stuff coming out of
that the crazy stuff coming out of this
MPD is the fact that smash did as well
as it did and it won out in terms of
exclusives for the year even beating
that was crazy to me because smash only
had three weeks to do it and Spiderman
had been out on the market for four
months whole thing is Erica as well is
that we everybody on this podcast
thought it was gonna be Pokemon not
smash number five best selling game of
2018 they said it's the best and also a
best-selling game of December 2018 the
fifth best selling game and then it
Sarah despite digital sales not
currently being tracked by the entity
group but just a franchise stand it's a
fast selling console exclusive ever
tracked by the NPD super smash ultimate
set a new launch month dollar sales
record for a platform exclusive in video
game history sales of 2010 was sold 3.3
million copies of Marvel's spider-man
within the first three days of release
that's the first
wasn't the first what's the total sales
of spider-man on please copyrighted
strike first one script three let's go
man
we got all right so real quick and then
from my personal my personal her a
moment and and fauns will be appreciate
this red dead redemption to the
best-selling game of the year yeah it
would be and it take taking out taking
out you know call the movies always up
there and why are people yawning I don't
know yeah it's so funny when it is
something they're not about and they're
happy about it's a non-story am I
supposed to care about your opinion next
not a lot of some moment let's go no you
go I'm done you can go ahead cardistry
Sony announced that spider-man for ps4
has sold 9 million copies physically and
digitally as get that smoke spy right so
you mean so you telling me that smash
smash stood in the face with the only
physical copies County man which came
out what July I too may have four months
to throw that nine million
so of the exclusive to any other because
they had nothing people who went out to
buy somebody was talking about the let's
talk yes I'm here
I have to leave here in three minutes
topic say your point on it and then
we'll finish it off so what's going on
with metroid man oh it looks like
Nintendo actually came I was gonna make
a video on it then I realized I don't
care but uh people made they made a
video and you know they came out and
they said look we had a lot of issues I
think it was who's responsible for
making that Erica I'm pretty sure you
know it was at Namco it was part of the
double yeah an echo never like they you
know I gotta respect them because you
know they came out and they said that
wasn't to their standard and they were
pretty much like you know hint hint we
want our product to be what we know it
should be and they and Nintendo the only
developer I know right now they'll come
but they've like now that in it all of
us gone we start right back over from
scratch and so you know that they
cancelled everything they deleted
everything that they worked on it's kind
of a similar to what happen with Final
Fantasy 7 and I just wanted like you
know I want to applaud them it's like
you know they're not getting backlash
Nintendo I feel like developers need to
take this more serious like when it
comes to communication people these
developers and publishers need more of
it like that they scrap that drag the
scalebound and the world ended that day
they spent scalebound
that's because that's because scalebound
was leaked that it got it got cancelled
first off they're not canceling Metroid
they're redoing it why because it looked
like scratch do that Microsoft was like
yeah it's gone yeah so what yeah I
guarantee you they had come out and said
yeah we're cancelling the mentor working
on and we have no idea when we're gonna
come back to it they'd be a problem but
they were transparent they're like look
like we know that people been asking
about it we don't want to hold that all
any longer we have to cancel all of the
work done now
doctoring credit to Skybound
real if Nintendo would have made a
proper console that was I got a hold
about to literally reiterate kind of my
same feeling which he said they need
better communication may be now more
Nintendo announcement was excellent
especially compared to bar wares last
night on anthem completely agree here's
the dick they didn't have to do this
like let's be real how many times we go
to e3 and either Sony or whatever
they'll throw up a JPEG image whatever
coming soon and the crowd goes wild and
then to e3 Escobar like deep down what I
could think of so many games that they
blow me to hear about crackdown for like
almost a year now I don't think you're
understanding my point about the console
though about I'm not just talking mess
what I'm saying is maybe Metroid Prime
for or too ambitious for the power of
this switch Unreal Engine and based on
Namco's involvement I could out give you
that to some extent that could
definitely be a possibility that
direction the thing I like about it is
number one retro studios who made the
actual good games the the prime the one
two three or whatever it was it's like
they weren't in
also the fact that they say you know
what shut that down that's not a go
we're gonna get the original US team
that was kind of doing it bringing them
back involved and we had more but the
end of the day to me the whole thing is
the messaging they didn't have to say
that to be they came out on stage I'm
like who died like it did actually look
like how they now the fair world thing
like it did kind of look like there's a
funeral he said no it's not going away
it's not too watched and indeed you
never say shout achieve when when retro
studios flies out there they're gonna
have one thing they're gonna say where
the console that oh my you're acting
you're acting like this let's say this
game comes out in four years right
you're acting like a Nintendo in four
years that that system is gonna be some
otherworldly powerful system which is
it'll be a switch with a 1080p screen
that's what you gonna have the leaps and
power that Nintendo is going to give us
in the next four five three honestly
think they're gonna keep with the
handheld yeah it would be stupid if they
didn't yeah the end of the day to me is
just about transparency whether it's
like I said good or bad gaming news this
tell me what's going on
I think the point of that it's the not
give us crappy game it goes back to that
Miyamoto uh Miyamoto quote is it you
know a delayed game is eventually good
but a rush game is bad no transparency
can also be an ugly word people I mean
come on
well here's the thing what's the
alternative for them not to say anything
we keep imagining that Metroid promise
three I agree that they should have said
this yeah 100% yeah I'm gonna tell
people that you know this game ain't
working out on this this these guys
don't have no and they said okay we can
do it we got Metroid Prime for here it
was a 240 P in frames
yeah me what I feel about Nintendo
they're such perfectionist like this
yeah you might laugh at that but they
really are like they want their game
polish this is why I tell people and I
said this on press start because we were
talking about 19 and why I feel it's a
little shaky Nintendo has a lot to do
with it in my opinion because these
games like we just never truly know when
they're coming like oh c'mon all this
stuff we don't know they they can't that
not cancel they delay games like crazy
it's just something they do and it's
something that just is what it is but
you guys ever notice when they do
like bad news sometimes it comes after
the good news we just had the NPD talk
right they're doing amazing smash is
amazing and then oh by the way Metroid
were giving it to retro it's gonna take
a while you know buddy beam sucks
it's a great way to soften the blow
right well they do have reasons why they
announce things why they do like it just
makes sense so but for me personally I
mean I set him a metric and I'm looking
forward to it whenever it comes it's
just win is always the question and
that's why sometimes I look at my switch
and I'm like damn I I guess I'm not
playing you for another minute I'm just
killing them back like smashed like
Zelda you know I didn't I don't I can
say is Nintendo's good in Nintendo this
isn't like nothing new to me I feel like
when I heard about Medford I was like
well I I mean I kind of called it like
you know next gen when we're playing at
4k 60 on the new consoles they're gonna
be a 1080 30 I'm not he's not lying this
is why that argument about the machine
not being powerful nervous foolish
because it won't be five years with an
actual opinion on this like I said
before like I said before I think giving
it to Bandai Namco from the jump was
kind of a mistake hey I didn't you know
maybe retro was working on the stuff
right
should have always been working on this
now mind you retro is not exactly the
same suit as it was before there only
maybe 15 or 16 employees that they're
still that worked on the primaries but
you do have the prime director that's
there so they know the kind of game that
a prime game is supposed to be and I
just think again they're like like I
said there's such perfectionist and a
metroid is one of those things that's
popular here not so much in Japan and
not nearly as popular as there's other
two big franchises so for me take as
long as you need to make the game um it
gives them more time to hopefully give
us the prime trilogy
um and bring that damn 3ds Metroid 2 to
switch Nintendo is though be
perfectionist right they'll take their
time on Zelda and all these big
franchises but then out of nowhere
they'll release Metroid Federation force
like I'll just do this stupid move yeah
no I mean that's just how they are
absolutely this is mind-boggling that's
all you I'm waiting for hailey pop
that's the Eternity day oh I see
you see Kings alternative is just blow
the system up so we already know just
sitting right up there my kids play
monsters they plays stuff and it's cool
I have no problem with it I'm just like
Josh and on it I just like the word
inurement and um for the smash to do
what it did that's fantastic
um is it a better game is fighting my
hell to the no um but it they don't have
anything and it was gonna sell a Metroid
they had to delay it because it's not up
to snuff
that's alright that's how we got it
let's add this James get out of it I'm
suggesting new yoyo this week with the
recent example of the anthem VIP demo
how concerned are you when developers
expressed as
specific aspects of the game balance an
economy will be changed exclusively for
the demo prior to release the choices
are a very concerned
gamers need to stay vigilant onward it
gives free ordering inaccurate games be
non-issue as long as the developer is
transparent with all the changes and why
and see I don't care no anthem servers
still got a hold that client Jordan face
people when he goes up tomorrow
lady absolutely you here let's start off
with lady Erica where can the find
people find you and what do you have
going on what I have going on okay so
you can catch me on press start podcast
every every Thursday 5:30 Pacific
oh just YouTube press Start podcast
you'll find it it's on Kofi's channel
I'm there I also have my my personal
YouTube which is air cuts for the win I
post content I do reviews I do a lot of
like boss fights I'm very into it like
the souls born stuff so whenever a game
like Sakura comes out I go hard and you
local rights I break down the game I
stream I also stream on Twitch so that's
twitch TV / air cuts for the more
consistent there I'd appreciate you guys
checking it out a subject we're gonna
have a description or information what's
in there absolutely as far as what I'm
up to I'm just waiting for for these
games
Sakura is like the number one freaking
on the backlog pretty much no doubt
thank you guys for having me seriously I
had a good time you definitely welcome
back any time you were hilarious love
your girl thank so much fun so much fun
Lord Fonzarelli my brother from another
mother always good to have you all even
when we disagree it's fine alone I go
everybody can find me at J Fonzarelli on
Twitter in here on YouTube making
content weekly now not a video week I
know it's not much but
with more than that so uh but companies
you can DM me I love all electronics get
meeow meeow J farm le on Twitter lewd
father absolute pleasure to have you
thank you so much brother bear
appreciate you being a good sport coming
in and like I say one thing I love about
Fonz is it like I said regardless to
whatever side of the fence beat him a
both on we can always talk about it we
can be respectful at the end of day
we're all passionate about these games
we love these games that's what it's
about
he's in the bush oh yeah - Erica -
coming through my heart oh man somebody
else before in the switch gang much
appreciated lady asked for the bag
that's my guy right there for the bag
first of all I like to thank Eric for
coming through and I also real
appreciate us floating the topic to you
and you being cool with the topic thank
you oh I really appreciate like if she
don't smoke I said wow thanks
oh yeah yeah Jay man missed the funds
are really words cannot express the
level of supports that you showed me you
all any time I post combat talk you're
in that combat tour and I really
appreciate it brother thank you so much
all the support you know and also for
trying to help me give us that anthem
the other day works I'm going to pull
you into that Instagram post up there
but we're changing around some stuff
with the tears on the patreon um and I
want you guys to understand like I have
to buy these games and we're gonna buy
all these games because so the patreon
members will get first dibs and fire
teams with the Lord's and the days
they're gonna go up sovereigns gonna
work hard on the days and put those days
up at the Lord's is gonna play with you
guys and when you our patreon
subscribers I got the exclusive bag tell
ya now I'll holla at Kofi you know maybe
we get a trainee scenario
yeah
the tears is gonna change and it's gonna
be a lot more interaction and picture
unsubscribes it's definitely valued and
you guys come first so we're always
looking for things and ways to make it
better for you guys more accessible and
join our discord get in there so talking
to the Lord's and listen unless you at
me I don't hear you
mm okay Cognito tell me it's called if
he does not respond unless you act him
so make sure you had him in before the
support thing in lady Erica Lord
Rawnsley fantastic show um look like
again hit that light as a scribe and
notification gang-up music that we get I
get a lot of messages I don't know when
we up you know hit that up you already
know chi box was gonna have the audio up
to SoundCloud iTunes Spotify all that
good stuff the links will be in the
description for both of them in their
Channel stars Erica and fawns and them
as far as the combat tour looking at the
combat talk up right now please check
that up on the on my Opie YouTube
channel as well as a potentially perfect
he's got a first look up I want to shout
out the stream team and they're going so
hard right now Lord snarl bow l Bergen
old-school-style
MJ is a boss and Lord the lab will
himself and the last word with myself
and the bouncers we will return next
Friday because Bungie you want to be
late with 12 so an anthem launch so
didn't launch it so make sure that's did
but that's all I got if anybody's got
anything else
alright let's get out of here everybody
enjoy your Sunday peace